this program is brought to you by Emory
University
the closest that we have I would say to
a stigma is that when you tell someone
when I tell people that I have moves the
first thing they says you don't have to
dark thing around your face well I'm not
that type of lupus patient that's about
is for a stigma I don't think people
know enough about it to stigmatize Lewis
is not a death sentence it's just a new
way of redefining life you know and the
more we do stories and educate the
community the more will you take
lewisham will whisper to a shell and so
now when I meet people i don't quickly
hear about so much the Deaf scented as i
hear people now saying you know what
I've heard that disease oh I know a
friend that has that disease she goes to
this doctor and so your conversation
start changing I met a six-year-old that
has looked as you know it dislike it's
no respecter of persons no respecter of
age your men that look at this is not a
woman's two demons into everybody's
asleep it's just as more prevalent in
women I'll be curious first if somebody
said I don't know what Lucas is not want
to know immediately what do you need to
know do you know somebody who says that
they have lupus or are you concerned
about someone or yourself and then that
would lead me to just ask them questions
I saw in a pamphlet once oh how you feel
every day are you tired all the time
because I am I how's your vision mine's
not been having chest pain going to the
bathroom the light doesn't smell funny
those kind of things I just when someone
wants to know what Lucas is I
immediately want to make sure that they
are not someone that needs dr. Lim then
once I decided that they're just curious
then I give them that professional
description it's an autoimmune disease
that can't may or may not take you out
of here that's usually just Alice there
and
depending on the questions that they
asked me that's what I give them because
like we said before is such a broad
thing it's such a broad knee and once I
tried to explain to someone verbatim
everything I knew and then like what
everybody's got loose and no so stitches
put that whole spiel out there then it
might confuse some people but if they're
asking specific questions I try and give
a specific and answer I can people ask
me all the time do you were young when
you've had heart disease do you think
it's from Lucas well before I would say
no and now I know that some of my heart
problems could possibly be linked to it
but you don't want also for people to
think that they might have a disease
where symptoms will come and go but if
you're talking about your heart or your
kidneys don't just say well if I had
lupus and it might come and it might go
and don't get yourself checked out you
need to get somewhere because those
things are very important so I'm real
cautious about how I explain what I feel
it is what I know it is and what someone
who thinks that they know someone with
this issue I want from them to be
proactive and go and see about
themselves or whatever their issue is
because it may not even be lupus but it
could just be that you got real bad hard
and you need to have it taken care of
you
the preceding program is
university